good morning believe nation today's
message is no means yes over to you
Sylvester Stallone what in this whole
world turns you on
challenge I really just I just love I
love it you know I love being told no it
just means yes no to you yeah what
turned you off lack of enthusiasm really
turns me off so this is an easy one for
me to relate to because I love big goals
I love challenges if it's too easy a
goal to accomplish then I'm not excited
I'm motivated by I love having the big
things to chase and I don't necessarily
love knows but the bigger your idea is
the more nose you're gonna get the more
rejection you're gonna get the more
you're gonna have people tell you that
you're crazy and you shouldn't do it and
so that that I love that stuff and so I
totally relate to Sly Stallone on that
one and my question the day is what big
project are you working on right now
that people are telling you know that
you're getting a lot of rejections on
share it in the comments below on the
journal discussion I look forward to
hearing what you have to say thank you
so much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso